[Music]
let's talk about these kicks down here
I thought I saw those coming through the
curtain oh yeah I'm doing a movie right
now called the vember rule and it's
about sneaker culture uh-huh and these
are I think one of the most rare pairs
of sneakers in the world they're worth
about $5,000 right yeah I know you get
killed over this kind of shoe yeah but
listen but you you're a very you're very
tight with it we talked abouts before
you were very tip of the dog you didn't
spend on it and I took them I looked the
producer in the irons like you know I'm
taking these right and they didn't say
no so I left the building with them
those are five baths you stole though
yeah those are stolen it's grand larceny
but I think that they won't prosecute
yes thanks Queen Latifah she produced
the movie okay all right and what makes
those sneakers so special like what
makes them worth $5,000 I don't know
you're not supposed to wear them outside
so after I wear them today I have to put
them in plexiglass is that true yeah and
I'm gonna trade them for a painting one
day what a strange thing to say for a
painting one day but I'm going to what
do you mean well I collect art and I
would rather have a piece of art than a
pair of shoes so when they double in
value to like $10,000 I'm gonna trade
them away to somebody and then you're
gonna get a piece of work yeah a
painting of wow that's not now let's
talk about something I heard that that
recently you said and I hope this is not
true that you were considering plastic
surgery and I heard that and I thought I
hope he's not really thinking about that
if it's not in the way you think as I've
gotten older I've gotten used to how I
look and I'm happy with how I look and I
realized that when I do that I look
handsome so I do that a lot now wait do
that again what it makes me look
handsome see that let me see that again
doing well with your eyes yeah look see
that look no look it makes me look
worried look at me I'm just worried I
stopped doing those
so - listen this isn't working for me at
all
Andy you try it maybe you get handsomer
[Applause]
[Music]
you handsomer me worried I look worried
and constipated anyway let's move on so
so what are you talking about you
wouldn't you wouldn't get plastics no no
no I went because I was looking at some
old photos from my first art of acting
and some old you know I did your show
the first time 14 years ago so I've
known you guys for 14 years now so I was
looking through a bunch of that like
going down memory lane and I realized
that my nose and ears are still growing
and so I went online and they grow for
the whole rest of your life that do yes
everybody in who was famous and pretty
in the 80s now look like a golden girl
because this keeps growing and gets
getting bigger right
and so our ears and your nose get bigger
and bigger and bigger right
right but I didn't want to change the
shape of it so I found this plastic
surgery in Beverly Hills and I went and
he said that they could go inside and
just shave off a quarter of an inch on
my ears and my nose
yep why why not I mean it won't change
my appearance except from the side right
so from the side you'd have a small less
prominent nose and less prominent yeah
because I'm preparing for the future
because oh well now you've sold me well
you can say that about anything I've got
a lot of onions in the basement why I'm
preparing for the future
you know it doesn't make sense but I'm
probably gonna do it for a couple more
years okay you're gonna wait a couple of
years and then he's gonna go and he's
gonna shave off cartilage here and
you're gonna retract but here's the
problem once you get started people
don't stop I know Nona do that then
you're gonna do this then you're gonna
say I don't like this and the next thing
you know I see you're gonna have a
monocle and a weird dino monocle you
want mine I do want a monocle I wouldn't
eBay a couple days ago to try to find
one I want a monocle and a bowler hat
well you have one in props why don't we
just skip that we have across the
perhaps fight of them I would save me
money give yeah you saw we're gonna give
you a monocle see if they can find a
monocle we'll get it paid before the end
of the show I love being on this show
yeah that's the reason guests come on
yeah yes come on not to prote you know
to promote something they're just like I
might get a moniker maybe a stuffed
parrot